bom pessoal imagine um empreendedor
empreendedor comum empreendedor como
qualquer um de vocês que de repente vira
um investidor mas isso quem vê a foto
não vê um filme não vê um filme que essa
jornada dura 39 anos empreendendo então
não foi de repente
na verdade tem um trabalho enorme no
meio do desse processo e desse período
irá investidor é é um cara que já passou
por tantas coisas erros fracassos
sucesso há muitos aprendizados que em
2018 resolveu é montar um site de venda
de ingresso
um site de venda de ingressos que
atendesse principalmente a minha empresa
uma empresa de eventos e site de venda
de ingresso e ele
ele precisava de muita coisa tá de
controle
saad estruturam e assim eu fiz foi
buscar e fui crescendo como qualquer
outro empreendedor foi desenvolvendo a
atividade empreendedora de ter um é como
é se de ter um site
mais do que isso eu percebi que eu podia
crescer com esse site
mas eu queria crescer com apoio com
ajudam e foi aí que eu fui buscar
investimento lá nos estados unidos tem
muito investimento para a startup
só que eu não sabia o que era uma
startup e eu fui buscar saber o que era
uma startup
foi quando eu apliquei para o fundo de
investimento chamado axon esse fundo de
investimento eu fiz um powerpoint
na perspectiva do que eu achava
importante falar
mostrando a estrutura que eu tinha três
escritórios 48 colaboradores carro
plotado toda a estrutura
naquelas aquela perspectiva minha fui lá
e apresentar esse powerpoint
cheguei lá apresentei só que eu não
falei o que eles queriam ouvir o que o
emprego o investidor quer ver são outras
coisas querem ver métricas capes quer
ver cuja condição de cliente quer ver a
taxa de cancelamento coisas que eu não
sabia o que era na verdade meu inglês
ainda um pouco é não técnico eu tive que
aprender tudo naquele momento e percebi
que o que eu precisava fazer para buscar
investimento mas eu recebi um categórico
não a partir daquele momento foi uma
mentoria foi não mais educador que eu já
tive na minha vida
a partir daquilo ali voltei pro brasil e
fiz um o que eu aprendi naquela reunião
eu pilotei o meu negócio e eu entendi o
que era ser uma startup que eu precisava
fazer para efetivamente me tornar uma
startup
e assim eu fiz transformei uma empresa
quem chama de pilotar num bicho be um
site não só de venda de ingressos mas um
site que pudesse prestar serviço para
resolver o problema de outras empresas
e aí transformei numa plataforma de
e-commerce uma plataforma de ingresso
mas esse processo de aprendizado me
ensinou muitas coisas que eu saí de três
escritórios foi para uma sala 3 por 4
com três colaboradores automaticamente
reduzir um custo de nome e passou a
sobrar muito dinheiro ou seja aquele não
foi muito educador
então como eu sou me sobrou muito tempo
eu comecei a olhar outros problemas e
comecei a conversar com outros
empreendedores e que tinha uma empresa
de tecnologia para mostrar e psiquê expo
também podiam ser startup
ele citou também podia desenvolver
negócios para o mercado
e foi aí que começou o meu trabalho de
mentoria e foi aí que comecei a fazer
investimento anjo me tornar um
investidor
em 2014 eu já tinha quase 40 negócios
investidos entre trabalho mentoria
investimento real e me tornei um
empreendedor que investe em 2015 mexeu
me juntei com outro investidor
o pierre ea gente desenvolveu uma
empresa de investimento chamado a bossa
nova que hoje é a maior micro venture
capital da américa latina
mas foi muito bom nós fomos muito mais
longe que isso muito mais longe que isso
nós queremos muito mais nós queremos ser
nós queremos investir em mil empresas
para ajudar no desenvolvimento econômico
do brasil mas o que é uma startup
finalmente que tanta gente fala essa
esse nome não é mais motivo tinha esse é
uma realidade mas startup pelo
aprendizado que eu tive
são negócios que são escaláveis modelo
de negócio com base digital que possam
escalar e não é escalonar não é crescer
não é só exponencial mas que eles possam
crescer faturamento sem crescer
infraestrutura proporcional ou seja a
receita cresce mais do que a despesa mas
isso é um aprendizado que eu fui fazendo
ao longo dos anos e fui aprimorando ao
longo dos anos
e aí essa história de modinha chegou no
brasil todo mundo fala de
a tap mas não tem isso não é isso não
existe outra alternativa a não ter que
conviver e se relacionar com uma startup
não tem uma empresa brasileira grande
empresa brasileira que quer inovar que a
dilma
de alguma forma não se relaciona com as
startups e aí você tem um celular na mão
você com certeza tem uma startup um
aplicativo do seu celular
é uma startup então eu digo não tem
outra forma ou você vai usar uma startup
você vai criar uma startup o
efetivamente você vai investir em uma
startup não é mais
modinha e qual é a oportunidade que nós
temos na mão a oportunidade para
empreendedores a desenvolver negócio
maneira muito mais simples e muito mais
fácil
usando todos estes conceitos antigamente
para empreender é muito difícil hoje
basta um celular uma idéia um protótipo
você consegue até validar um negócio com
muito menos recursos
isso é uma oportunidade para
empreendedores e uma oportunidade também
para investidores para investir nesse
negócio e é sobre isso que vim falar com
vocês sobre investimento anjo e o que é
investimento anjo investimento é
dinheiro anjo é fazer o bem então é o
dinheiro que faz bem
ou seja é uma pessoa que dá não só
dinheiro mas dá também mentoria apoio
conexões indicações aval infraestrutura
e muito mais para o empreendedor é o
cara que sofre junto que comemora junto
que pega na mão e vai junto
e qual é o negócio efetivo por trás
dessas startup para os empreendedores é
uma oportunidade de através do capital
intangível que é aquele que não pega o
capital tangível é o que se pega o
intangível intelectual através do
capital intelectual através de pouco
recurso fazer muito com muito pouco eles
conseguem desenvolver negócios que podem
ser muito útil que amanhã pode ser
gigantesco e para os inventores a
oportunidade é exatamente isso de deixar
de investir só no capital tangível e
passar a investir nesses negócios que
está ajudando não só a multiplicar o
capital deles mas também ajuda no
desenvolvimento econômico ajuda esses
empreendedores ajuda o mercado porque
quantos e quantos negócios podem
aparecer a partir dessa possibilidade de
fazer muito com muito pouco quase nada
existem vários estágios de investimento
no processo
é uma escada de investimento então o
empreendedor que está com a ideia ele é
um estágio empreendedor que está
validando um estágio empreendedor que
está operando ou tracionando em outro
estágio e existem investidores para cada
estágio então começa lá com incubação
aceleração investimento anjo presse
decidi ser e abcd até o irb ou essa
escada de investimento que é um processo
de fã do oasis né de captação de
investimento ela existe e é real existe
no brasil também muitos investidores e
empreendedores hoje fazendo essas
rodadas de investimento o negócio é
descobrir em que momento em que estágio
você tá pra saber o investimento que
você precisa
o que buscamos e apostamos no nosso caso
nós buscamos empreendedores que já estão
operando
buscamos empreendedores que conseguem
crescer mas que eles precisam chegar no
ponto de equilíbrio nós buscamos
empreendedores que que entende o que a
gestão entende que o negócio dele é
muito bom e para onde ele pode crescer
mas que eles estão se preocupando agora
em organizar e estruturar a empresa dele
pra crescer e no nosso ponto de vista
não é o que exponencial mais rápido que
vence nós por esse nosso ponto de vista
é aquele que cresce bem mas cresce de
forma consistente e estruturada esse é o
nosso esse é o nosso motivo de fazer
isso por isso a gente investe nesse
negócio a pergunta que mais me fazem
joão onde eu encontro investidor onde
procurar investidores
eu tenho um livro chamado smart mantém
esse livro na primeiras páginas já
mostram mais de 350 investidores que
fazem com que a gente faz no brasil são
mais de 7 mil no brasil investindo em
negócios inovadores e por isso gente
existem investidores você precisa apenas
procurar pela tese dele se você tem um
negócio de saúde procure por
investidores de saúde e assim
sucessivamente
não fique procurando fora da tese e mais
do que isso você procura por exemplo por
um grupo de investidores
o ex aluno de universidade grupo de anjo
grupo de anjo e profissionais se pode
procurar por exemplo o perfil desses
investidores no linkedin por exemplo
então tudo isso é possível e não existe
investidores no brasil que fazem isso o
problema é descobrir identificar qual é
o estágio e qual é a fase que você tá
pra achar o investidor correto para você
a dica empreendedor que eu deixo para
qualquer empreendedor que quer buscar
investimento é você que tem que escolher
o investidor e não o contrário
é a gente que escolhe primeiro baseado
na tese mas a dica que eu quero deixar
pra você é que você precisa entender o
que você tem o que você quer
principalmente onde você quer chegar e
você precisa validar aquele projeto
antes mesmo de apresentar e quando você
foi apresentar o investidor apresente
primeiro problema a solução e como você
vai resolver aquilo não é onde você
estudou não é carteirada sou formado em
que ali está a obrigação sua estudar e
se formar mas o obriga o que a gente
quer ver é que problema e qual o
problema você resolve então eu quero ver
se posso deixar uma dica empreendedora
pra quem tá buscando investimento é
entenda qual o problema se resolve e
muito cuidado com arrogância e com a
afirmação porque é uma linha muito tênue
se mostra humilde porque aquele que
pensa que sabe tudo não sabe de nada e
empreendedor gosta de empreendedor que
houve mais do que fala então essa é a
dica que eu deixe empreendedores e e
porque isso porque todo em todo estado
que eu conheço que é ser unicórnio né
quer buscar a impressão empresa de 1
bilhão de dólares mas antes ela precisa
entender que empreender no brasil é
muito difícil que empreende no brasil
empreende qualquer lugar do mundo porque
nós temos vários e vários desafios e
barreiras aqui no brasil
e aí o empreendedor que consegue
entender que ele começa sendo barata
barata que se pise a não morre
saí correndo ele precisa passar a ser
cabra da montanha primeiro antes de
pensar em ser um unicórnio porque acaba
da montanha consegue subir uma montanha
de 90 graus
já vi uma cabra subindo uma montanha de
90 graus ela existe e eu digo que o
empreendedor precisa criar uma
habilidade e competências e desenvolver
habilidades para subir para poder
liberar os alas se alimentar
então o empreendedor ele precisa pensar
primeiro em estruturar o negócio dele
subir a montanha para depois crescer e
buscar ser um unicórnio não é fácil e
poucos empreendedores conseguem entender
esse processo e aí meus amigos muita
outra pergunta que todo mundo me faz
joão qual é qual é a sua melhor startup
com essa melhor tratado como é que você
lida com tudo isso esse processo
são mais de 502 investimentos qual é o
melhor time eu identifiquei que
investimento e todo tudo que eu passei
nessa fazendo dessa longa história uma
pequena história rápida pra vocês uma
história de muito muita luta muitos os
desafios foi que esse é um processo de
educação tanto dos empreendedores comigo
quanto aprendizado como investidor em
meio ao aprendizado gente foi dentro de
casa também é melhor estar tap são meus
filhos meus filhos são melhor startup
minha melhor forma de educação eu já
levei pra dentro de casa tudo aquilo que
eu fiz com os empreendedores nesses
últimos 11 anos fazendo a mesma coisa
investindo em gente
então a gente investe em pessoas de que
antes de ter de negócio é preciso
entender de gente e ele lá em casa
nós criamos um uma uma mentalidade um
modelo de desafiar eu não dou mesada
aliás nunca dei mesada todos eles são
desafiados a buscar coisas que eles não
têm eles são incomodadas e insatisfeitas
no bom sentido e assim que o
empreendedor tem que ser porque se foram
incomodados souberem que terão essa
garantida eles não vão correr atrás e
nada na vida garantindo se você dá
mesada é como se você tivesse dando fixo
garantido com muito cedo
lá eu conheço jovens que 22 anos 23 anos
sabe o que quer da vida
em todos os meus filhos sabe a maioria
de nove anos por exemplo essa menina que
hoje tem 15
a maria aos nove anos vendia churros
brigadeiro mole na doceira maravilhosa
só que é uma empreendedora por
necessidade
ela só vende quando precisa é até hoje
ela não é uma empreendedora nata ela
vende quando precisa qual o problema de
ser um empreendedor por necessidade
o meu mais velho hotel ele é um
empreendedor por oportunidade
o hotel por exemplo lembra do site de
ingressos que eu falei pra vocês quando
ele tinha 15 anos hoje ele tem 21 disse
theo é fica administra a minha empresa
de ingresso ele falou 'não eu não quero
a sua empresa vai montar um concorrente
e notou um concorrente como é que se
lida com isso um concorrente dentro da
sua casa e foi assim e isso aconteceu
dentro de casa porque eles têm uma
mentalidade empreendedora foi o tempo
todo desafiados lá em casa a gente fala
de problema lá em casa a gente fala de
solução
lá em casa a gente tá todo mundo e
pensando não só para empreender negócios
mas empreender a vida empreender av
da buscar alternativas para os problemas
mais difíceis que existem e o davi que
esse rapazinho aqui
ele montou uma startup com 13 anos uma
startup de material escolar e como lidar
com isso uma startup dentro de casa não
é mais uma está cap além das que já
trabalhava e ele que resolveu o problema
que que resolver o problema de mães e
pais na história de material escolar no
mercado
assim ele fez me pediu investimento eu
disse não porque tem que ser fácil pra
ele se não é para nenhum de nós e não
foi pra mim o não foi educador pra mim
tem que ser educador pra ele ele mesmo
assim ele fez ele pediu dinheiro
emprestado e silva está não vou te
investir
emprestei ele e desenvolveu o software
lá fez um vídeo fez um cartão de visita
apresentou tocou negócio mas no primeiro
faturamento eu disse pode me devolver o
dinheiro ele falou hoje o país já já
devolva e me arrependo até hoje não ter
cobrado juros por esse dinheiro
o davi é é agora com 18 anos morando nos
estados unidos há mais de dois fazendo
faz hoje faz universidade da vida
terminou vender a empresa dele esse ano
para o maior concorrente dele e hoje não
tem mais essa empresa então havia um
jovem que já fez saída ele fez e
desenvolver o negócio eo empreendedor
que conseguiu vender sem a ajuda do pai
eu nunca dei nada pelo corpo pelo
contrário cobrei gente é eu só estou
mostrando a família para vocês
entenderem que como a gente pensa no
processo de educação de empreendedor de
startup é muito parecido com uma forma
que eu lido com meus filhos meus filhos
até reclama por pais e me trata como
estátua mas é assim e assim tem que ser
nada pode ser fácil para eles porque não
foi fácil o pai dele e quando eu digo
que quem vê a foto não ver o filme é
porque não foi fácil chegar e não foi
fácil se tornar um investidor não é
fácil ser por quinto ano consecutivo um
dos melhores investidores do brasil
gente eu queria dizer pra vocês que por
poucas as poucas coisas que eu disse que
a gente tem uma oportunidade hoje para
empreendedores desenvolver empresas e
nós temos a oportunidade hoje para
investidores investir nessas empresas
isso é real isso não é mais moda a gente
pode ter grandes negócios no brasil ea
gente já tá
vendo isso acontecendo com grandes
empresas até se tornando um unicórnio
empresas que vão estão estruturando
estão mudando a cara do brasil nessa
nova economia
essa economia digital e eu queria um por
fim dizer pra vocês assim e de realmente
mostrar que é esse
efetivamente o grande negócio que existe
por trás de todas essas startups
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]